wedding bells are ringing because we are
in the midst of a wedding boom as 26
million weddings are expected this year
and whether you are getting married or
attending as a guest something important
we have to think about is the wedding
registry so joining us today from the
not registry store is lauren k hi lauren
how are you
hello so great to see you you too i
needed you about a year ago when i was
getting ready for my wedding and doing
my registry but let's talk about it
there are so many different options of
things to add onto your registry so what
are some of the trending things we're
seeing this year
absolutely you're right there is no
shortage of things to add and it really
depends on the couple i think after the
last few years of covet everyone is
feeling liberated to ask for what they
really want so we're noticing a couple
of trends one classic items still on the
rise so things like your kitchenaid
mixer your roomba vacuum but now couples
are prioritizing experiences so this
could be anything for helping adopt a
puppy fund taking a honeymoon or even
tickets to a sporting event or something
local to your community that allows you
to get out and have an experience with
your new someone special
well and i love the knot site overall
because you guys just make it so easy to
do everything and something else that i
think is really cool is having that
option for the honeymoon fund i thought
that was amazing can you tell us a
little bit more about that
absolutely so on the not registry store
you can go on and select some items to
help make the honeymoon of your dreams
happen so this could be anything from a
couple's massage to dinner out and all
of this translates to cash for you to
actually put towards your honeymoon so
instead of asking for gifts which you
might already have you can actually ask
for the experience of a lifetime which
is going to create incredible memories
for you and your new
spouse
and on top of all of that i know that
not overall does a lot of great things
in the community but you guys also
partner with different charities that
are tied back through the wedding
registry how does that work
absolutely so we definitely support
charities we also love the idea of
couples being able to choose a charity
to support so in addition to registering
for physical items or experiences you
can also donate to a charity so if
there's something near and dear to your
heart you can add it to your registry
and ask your guest to contribute there
and if people are a little overwhelmed
by the process what would you suggest as
kind of being that first step to
starting the registry
absolutely well we just released our
annual registry awards you can find it
on the knot.com and that's a great place
to start you can see all the things that
were highly rated by us and recommended
and you can determine what you need for
your life together and what maybe you
could put on the back burner and
prioritize something else that's more in
tune with your lifestyle today
well lauren thank you so much the knot
was a huge help during all of my
planning so i always recommend it to
everyone so thank you for breaking it
all down for us we really appreciate it
absolutely all right mercedes i'll turn
it over to